oh hey guys it's Hannah from BuzzFeed
and today I'm partnering with
realtor.com for this amazing opportunity
to help a couple who loves to host find
their dream house tell me a little bit
about yourself we've been together for
13 years we are from Florida and we just
moved to California about two years ago
and we are finally starting to buy a
home the last few years we've been
living in the smallest studio like ever
to save up we have enough money to like
at least put a down payment for a home
Oh awesome I think we can start with a
three-bedroom just see what we can find
now buying a house is a big deal this is
a huge milestone for any couple to
expand into a family to grow inside a
place and it's a place that you're going
to live for likely a very long time
thoughts on family no one hold messages
I feel like each person in a couple has
their list of make-or-break priorities
do you each kind of have your own things
that you're looking for I really really
want a big closet and a big backyard for
our kids your priority is like an island
at the kitchen she loves to cook I am
especially excited about this because my
family just went through the whole
process of buying our first home I love
my house so much I got it tattooed on my
arm oh my gosh I really like this one I
think I can cook everything pretty sure
what's the description sight fully
permitted any quick
studio apartment if you guys wanted to
rent that out that could be a really
great opportunity for this house agree
that's what's very cool now make sure to
save this search and heart any of the
homes you like because if there's a new
listing that pops up in this search
criteria or any of these prices drop
you'll get a notification directly to
your phone wow that's really helpful
sunny California right first home
initial vibe I really love the white
picket fence that's very holding for me
I feel like it's time to just get inside
and start looking yes when you're like
washing dishes and your kids are outside
you can just like what are you doing
over there stop hitting your brother
you look like full visibility well
dinners being laid into the first
bedroom I like the windows I like that
all the tiles are different never rains
in Southern California it seems like
it's almost a 360 yard I kind of feel
like I'm gonna see the lauder rings it's
beautiful let's get cozy by this unlit
for her planks I just want to get your
initial thought and feelings about this
house pros/cons
what did you think my favorite was set
up with the master bedroom I just think
it doesn't seem a bit too close to the
street for me like I want to be able to
be at ease well I wanted an island
something you have to figure out yeah we
can work with yeah all right let's go
take a look at the second house amazing
let's do it
you guys were super concerned about
being too close to the street at the
last house you have your own private MO
yes property let's just get inside start
looking at the houses gonna go we got
the yellow shutters looks good I want
two yellows or to not see yellow this is
gorge
gives you a very warm Bible you come in
this is upstate and there's no island
but there's a lot of room in this it's a
lot of rooms we wanted to make an item
we actually do is that about there yes
it is this is gonna be my stylist room
this must be the master bedroom
the other one was a little bigger so
bigger it's pretty might as well check
out the studio to see how big that is
maybe there's some storage in there oh
my gosh this is so cute
I did not realize this had so much in
here they have the big mirrors funny
because they have a big mirror in here a
full-size rear that we want it okay you
guys we only have one bathroom in the
other house but if we rent this out you
lose about there yeah the space is just
utilized properly
in here let's see this backyard wow it's
so green look orange rest my say Florida
we could build a pool if he wanted to
really would be nice good idea
I really love it too it's nice so after
seeing both houses shall we waste some
frozen Commons about each yes house
number one the bathroom for one really
stuck out to me the closet space I love
the big mirrors so what was that house
missing for you guys I think for me it
was too close to the street it's too
busy a little bit too loud house number
two we couldn't rent out the studio help
us get back on our feet for the first or
second year I like that it's further
away from the street I like the layout
of the house of mrs. kitchen I wanted
her kids not blood back at work it's
only one bathroom in this entire house
so that might be a little bit of problem
for all of us to share if you're having
a party at house number one pick out of
five party hats
how many party hats to the kick for okay
house number two there you go is your
dream Oh
drum roll greeters house number
- this is Arthur and this is something
that we really wanted all this lip to do
is go to realtor calm we'll get you a
realtor and get this process started you
guys are gonna buy a house oh my gosh
congrats this is the main thing and then
you tell me when it's time to set up our
tattoo appointments to get our matching
house tattoos we'll just make it a club
it'll be a thing
[Music]